they came from across south africa and
neighbouring countries to welcome a new
king
zulu warriors in their thousands to
witness the first coronation of a zulu
king in more than 50 years and pledge
allegiance to king misizulu kazulitini
the ninth king of the zulu nation the
largest ethnic group in south africa in
what's known as the sacred kral messi
zulu is presented to his ancestors the
kings who came before him
[Applause]
he's accompanied by the prime minister
of the zulu nation and his uncle prince
[ __ ] suta butalezi seen as an
endorsement much of the ceremony that
follows is shrouded in secrecy
including traditions that go back
generations not meant for the public eye
or allowed to be filmed
the public is only allowed to see
certain rituals
we are praying to the zulu ancestors
where they sleep today
we are asking them to protect our new
king
we are also here to pray that god may
grant him wisdom
rise king we welcome you now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the coronation has not been without
controversy two other family members say
they are the rightful heirs and took the
mata to court to stop the ceremony but
failed
but other family members attended to
support the new monarch one of them
reminding the king his role is to serve
the nation
outside the main ceremony throngs of
people gathered this is so important to
you know us like that so that you can
know our background everything about us
i'm here to celebrate my king missy zulu
who was being crowned today as the new
king i'm so happy to be here everyone is
happy and it's a beautiful day
even as the new king departs our mabutu
or zulu warriors continue to sing his
praise and display their loyalty to him
they say they're willing to defend him
at any cost but many others here are
hoping the new king just like his father
will be a unifying figure for the zulu
nation for miramala al jazeera non-gomer
south africa